PROFESSOR: OK, so this is the
picture you've studied so far.
And now we will
consider the next thing.
So basis states.
What's going to happen?
We have to deal
with basis states.
We have electron spin.
We have electron
angular momentum.
What is the total
angular momentum?
The sum of them.
We will have to deal with that.
So we will have to deal with
addition of angular momentum
in the hydrogen atom.
It's awfully important.
That's the key of the matter.
So let's see what we have.
Let's look at our basis states.
So now the spin, the
most important thing,
we take it very seriously.
Recall that when you
have angular momentum--
in general, we use j and m,
and those are the two quantum
numbers, j squared, the
angular momentum eigenvalues,
h squared, l times--
j times j plus 1.
And jc over h bar
has eigenvalues, m.
That's a notation
for angular momentum.
So we have the electron spin.
So what is the notation.
It's sms, and it's
always equal to 1/2,
because the electron
always has been 1/2.
The electron will have many
orbital angular momentum, 0, 1,
3, but spin, it
only has been 1/2.
So s is always 1/2.
ms can be plus minus 1/2.
So that's two states.
For orbital electron,
orbital, we have l and m.
Those are the names, l and
m is the quantum number.
So how do we define
the uncoupled basis?
The uncoupled basis
is a set of states
that enumerates the whole
spectrum of the hydrogen atom,
using those quantum numbers to
distinguish all those states.
So the uncoupled basis are
those states that we have there.
Uncoupled basis are
all these states,
and they're described by n, and
the principal quantum number,
l and m.
This is the orbital.
And you could say,
well, s and ms,
that would be a
correct thing to do.
But as we said, s is always
So copying and copying again,
something that is
always the same value
and doesn't have
any new information
is not worth it, so people
don't include the s.
And we put ms.
And that's electron spin along
the z direction, electron sz.
And it takes values
plus minus 1/2.
So this is our uncoupled basis.
For any electron
in that table, you
need to know uniquely
that electron state.
You need to give me
all these numbers.
You have to tell me
where I am horizontally,
after that, where I am
vertically, I'm sorry,
for m, where I am horizontally
for l, within the multiplate,
which is my value of m.
And once you've done that,
you should tell me up or down.
So all those numbers
are important.
They're one to
one correspondence
to the basis state.
But now, let's do
the coupled basis.
That's where things
begin to get interesting.
Coupled basis.
So we'll consider the
total angular momentum
j, which is l plus s.
When we add angular
momentum, we basically say,
you know, you have states
that are representations
of orbital angular
momentum and spin.
But I want you to express
those as eigenstates
of the total angular momentum.
That's all adding
angular momentum means.
It's recognizing that we
want to re-express our basis
states in terms of eigenstates
of the total angular momentum.
It's all you do.
So what do we do then?
We have an l multiplate.
What does an l multiple mean?
That's a set of
vectors, a vector space.
And we tensor it with
a spin multiplate,
and the result is equal
to the sum of j multiplate
because your states are nothing
else but tensor products
of these things, even
though we never wrote it
in the way of tensor product.
Basically, the wave
function has some expression
having to do with
l and m in here
and has some value of the spin.
So a given state has
all these properties.
A given state lives
in the tensor product,
and we want to write it
the sum of j multiplate.
So I want to say a couple
more things about this.
When we do addition
of angular momentum,
what happens to the
quantum numbers?
That's, again,
also a thing that's
sometimes a little subtle,
and I want to emphasize it.
So an l multiple it is
described by l and m.
A spin multiplate is
defined by s and ms.
But when you have a j
mulitplate, you have j and j--
how do they call it?
jm.
I think they call it.
Yeah, jm.
But actually, you
have a little more.
I claim that the states--
so this is what I'm
meaning my this.
These states have two quantum
numbers you can specify.
You cannot specify any more.
This is the z component of l,
and you cannot specify the x
or the y component.
Here is all you can
specify of these states.
You certainly can
specify the value of j,
and the value of jm, the m
component, the z component
of j, but can you specify more?
And the answer is yes.
You can specify a little more.
You can actually specify
here all the states in here
are eigenstates of l,
of s, of j, and of jm.
So you add two more.
This may sound a little
funny, but every state here
had the same l eigenvalues.
They were, for
example l equal 3.
So all the states
have l equal 3.
All the states are eigenstates
of l squared, eigenstates.
All these states here are
l squared eigenstates,
and all the states here
are s squared eigenstates
with the same eigenvalues.
So if you multiply them,
and you rearrange them,
because that's all this
addition of angular momentum
is is just rearranging
the states,
you still have that all
the states that are here
have the same l squared
and the same s squared.
So l and s are good
quantum numbers here.
The things that are not good
quantum numbers are m and ms
are not good.
They are not good quantum
numbers of this state.
They are not
eigenstates of m or ms.
So this is something you've
learned with addition
of angular momentum.
If this is a little fuzzy,
it will be important
that you review it and make
sure this becomes clear.
There will be [? stuffed ?]
recitation about these things,
and we'll do more with it.
But now, what is the application
in the hydrogen atom for this?
Well, our multiplates
are multiplates
of [INAUDIBLE]
value of l that are
being tensored with spin 1/2.
Orbital l, and
when you have this,
you know that the answer is
l plus 1/2 plus l minus 1/2.
Those are the two values of j,
j max, and j min in this case.
So in the hydrogen
atom, the notation
is that this is the l state
with j equal l plus 1/2.
This is the j value plus the
l state with l minus 1/2.
So this is the capital L
we were mentioning before,
in this case L of l.
And our notation is evolving.
This is the spectroscopic
notation in which we
will describe states by an nLj.
So that's the
spectroscopic notation.
You put the principal quantum
number, the capital L,
that is for L equals 0, put
an s, a p, a d, and the number
which is the value of j here.
So let's look at
our spectrum again.
We have to do that.
It's an important thing.
So we'll do three cases
here, n equal 1, n equals 2,
and n equals 3.
We have l equals 0, l
equal 1, l equals 2.
And that's s, p, and
D. OK, let's begin.
This state, ground state,
what is the ground state?
It's l equals 0, tensor with
1/2 for the ground state.
This is just the state 1/2.
So it will be a state
with j equal 1/2.
So it should be written as
n, which is a 1, the capital
L, which is 0.
So it's s and the j value 1/2.
That's the state.
1s 1/2.
Go here.
Well, that's still l equals 0.
So this product source is
2s 1/2, and here is 3s 1/2.
That's the name
of the multiplates
in the coupled basis.
What do we have here?
We have l equals 1.
So with l equals 1,
we have 1 tensor 1/2.
So we will get j
equals 3/2 and 1/2.
So we must have 2.
What is the value of l?
Remember, the value
of l is preserved.
So if this was l equals 1,
after you do the tensor product,
l is still a good
quantum number.
So you have 2p 3/2, and 2p 1/2.
Here, you would have two
states, 3p 3/2 and 3p 1/2.
Finally, here l
equals 2, you have
2 tensor 1/2 is 5/2 plus 3/2.
So you would have
3D 5/2 and 3D 3/2.
Those are your states.
This is the notation
we will use.
So what is the uncouple
basis at the end of the day?
The uncoupled basis is n.
You still have n.
What is the coupled basis now?
We have the uncoupled
basis being this.
The coupled basis is still n.
Still l.
We said l carries through.
Still s would carry through,
but we don't have it there.
Now I cannot put m.
m is no good when [INAUDIBLE],,
but I have j and jm.
So these are your coupled
basis states, coupled basis.
And it's represented in
this notation, the n,
the little l is representative
for whatever letter is here,
the j is here, and well,
the jm is not said,
but that's a multiplate.
OK, so we've rewritten the
stating the couple basis,
because we will need
those states in order
to do perturbations theory.